let's
let's focus on uh a biden and let's
focus on
obama okay when obama first got elected
the threat was oh this guy may be a
communist you guys got to be careful
because
you know his father when he wrote the
book about his father and you know
mother and the influence that he had in
his life growing up and van jones when
he was first van jones used to be linked
to a comment
but oh my gosh this guy may be communist
i don't want to go any guy got elected
okay i mean he did some stuff but obama
wasn't as scary
as people thought he was going to be
right i would say
even as somebody that's fiscally
conservative registered independent
people thought he was going to be
a lot a lot of people were worried about
what he was going to do
fundamentally changing things now you
got a sanders he is
fully fundamentally on a complete
opposite side
aoc fully on a whole different side like
bernie sanders probably doesn't think
that obama did enough
like he should have done this and he
should have done that and secretly he
probably feels
disappointed with the amount of uh uh
social programs that obama came up with
or didn't come up with right
what i'm trying to what i'm asking here
is the following i'm trying to find out
for myself
and maybe this is a selfish question i'm
asking
the world knows socialism doesn't work
the world knows communism doesn't work
the world knows you can't
show a product that was developed from
that system
even all these countries like russia and
china eventually said dude we got to get
to this capitalism system to
give people to own businesses and have
identity and all this other stuff
what is the motive to get the only
country left in the world that's the
leading country in the philosophy of
capitalism
if this thing goes a lot are going to
follow why
why would you drive the initiative of
socialism knowing that doesn't work what
is the motive behind that
it's got to be more than the professors
thinking the fact that the plumber's
making 500
000 without a degree it's got to be
bigger than that what's the motive
it operates on many levels that that's
just one level here's another level
you've got all these young people
and they are they are actually living in
the middle of technological capitalism
but they're a little bit like the fish
that is not really conscious of the
water
because the water is all around them so
their world includes
uber and iphones uh and
airbnb and gps now none of this would
have come without technological
capitalism right
if you had left it up to the post office
for example they probably wouldn't even
have thought of overnight mail
it took outside age private companies
like ups and fedex
and then then the post office goes oh
wow you know even though the airplane's
been around for a hundred years
you know we can still do that we can do
it now so they got
but no innovation comes out of
government per se or very little
um but for a lot of young people they
take all this for granted they never
think about
how did they how did all these things
come to be they didn't magically fall
out of the sky
what is the system that produced them
they don't think about that
rather what they think about is simply
this they they have
and i think their professors are very
complicit in this have inculcated in
them
the honest belief that capitalism is
unjust
and in fairness i have to say that the
defenders of capitalism don't do a good
job
in explaining why it is just not just
why it is efficient
but just so for example if a guy makes
something
uh let's just say let's just take me as
an author for example now if i write a
book
and i publish it and it happens to be
during the great depression
uh and uh nobody buys the book the book
is let's say a failure
and then ten years later the economy
recovers and is doing better and i issue
the same book and it's a massive success
think about it's the same book in terms
of the merit of it
i've released the same product but in
one environment it's unsuccessful
in another environment i'm a millionaire
so the
ordinary guy looking at that goes well
how can a system be just
when the same product in two different
environments produces a completely
different outcome so
this what happens is young people are
raised to believe that there's something
completely arbitrary
about the rewards of capitalism and
therefore they become vulnerable to the
argument hey
why don't we have a different
organization maybe socialism in the old
sense doesn't work
but it is partly you know the american
optimism that says we can find a way
that's going to make it work
we're going to find a way that will
leave all the problems of the past
behind and so for example one common
thing you hear
politicians say is we don't want
authoritarian socialism you know we
don't want the socialism of mao
and lenin and stalin we're not going
there we want
democratic socialism and so if you
listen to aoc
or bernie sanders they almost never use
the word socialism without the adjective
democratic yes why because they believe
that democracy
this idea of popular consent gives more
legitimacy
to the idea of socialism so they're
trying to create in fairness they're
trying to create something of a new type
of socialism that hasn't existed before
the only question is when something has
been tried not once or twice
but 25 times across virtually
two-thirds of the world and failed every
single time
what makes you think it's going to
succeed now
[Music]